[Music]
throughout my childhood I was told by my
teachers and parents and I believed that
I was not creative because I was used to
Siddharth and although I learned how to
play the piano I was told to give up
after great one because I was tone-deaf
it was only after I became an
entrepreneur that I learned that the
most important skill for anyone in
business is creativity and I discovered
that I was actually extremely creative
this week Lucy Noble the artistic
director at the Royal Albert Hall called
for creative arts to be made compulsory
at GCSE level to stop a decline before
it's too late
every student she says should do at
least one creative subject until they're
16 she is absolutely right
creativity is needed in every walk of
life not least in business where we rely
on the creativity of entrepreneurs to
drive job creation so let's make this
happen
if we don't we are wasting a huge
opportunity kara what Lucy Noble said at
first glance makes absolute sense but if
you're a young man or a young woman and
you're absolutely committed to be an
engineer or your mum and dad or mom or
dad have been a doctor or so and you
just want to beam as your whole life
revolves around medicine why would you
make a young man or woman endure two or
three years of learning history or
whatever it might be why would you Ness
it if that is what they want to do well
that's why that's why they bring me in
if that's what they do because all
you're going to do that chart just wants
to be a doctor let him or her be before
I respond I'd love to be such an
impoverished attitude towards education
education is not just about churning out
the future job professional whatever
skill you need to do your work it's
about creating rounded people who can
contribute to the society who can engage
who are interested we have such as
doctors to college
life yep why should you stop children
exploring because I don't want to
talents they might not know that he/she
does my education system is not to just
give you a specific skill set it is to
broaden your understanding to give you
the opportunity to find these you might
not know you had and you know Karen's
absolutely right I was thinking about
this in terms of the creative industry
the creative sector is worth 92 billion
to our economy the fastest growing
sector it's great seven times the rate
of other sectors but actually it's not
just about being given the opportunity
to work in the creative sector it's
about if you want to be an entrepreneur
he wants to be a banker if you want to
be a surgeon saying is grounded in the
Edwardian era you'll now understand that
children learn through multidisciplinary
Shrieker artistic ideas things from
music and enhance science and that is I
mean welcome to viewpoints to this event
first of all what 14-year old really
knows what they want to do ask that well
point one point to I think the nature of
the way our economy is moving I agree
with our four by the way is this
becoming multidisciplinary so it's
worthwhile having this broad toolkit so
that we can actually contribute to the
economy for I have you have various
roles you're not just a radio tower on
TV I imagine columns the last thing I'll
say is actually I think where your your
scenario I can paint that I can pay take
an opposite scenario as well so
especially within minority ethnic
communities but South Asian communities
I know intimately well our parents only
ever encouraged us to be plumbing
engineers doctors technology we have
basically engineering colleges one and a
half million students apply every year
school leavers
130,000 make it to the first cut and
10,000 get a place that's more difficult
than Oxford came I remember explicitly I
stood ice to design patterns in the back
of people's hair when I was about 13 14
with with the Clippers I was very
artistic
I did not GCSE that's the only a I got
for my GCSEs because I wasn't into my
studies right yeah a servant you're
doing
this is because I remember once my yep
my parents saying to me as a young me
what did you want to do when you grow up
and I said I want to continue doing
these patterns in people's hair and they
were they were horrified you had to be a
dentist actually it was a lawyer right
and so and then what I did is I did my
Jesus is 16 I enrolled in graphic design
at barking college but pulled out of
that to do a levels because you know my
dad wanted me to be a lawyer in the end
at university so desperate was I to do
the Arts well I mean law is related but
I added a language to my law degree
because then it was Arabic right because
I wanted to pursue the arts and
humanities and I think so there is an
opposites knives are the one you've
painted and that's kids it's not
either/or I really believe that STEM
subjects again we are encouraging our
students in this country to go for
science technology engineering and maths
we need to but it they should also study
art subjects as a combination of two
that gives us that just to hear cuz
we've heard that this was triggered by
Lucy noble the artistic director at the
Royal Hall and this is what she actually
said she said austerity measures and the
continuing tendency for schools to focus
on more academic subjects risk having a
negative and irreversible long term
impact on the arts field for which
Britain is respected all over the world
we are calling for at least one creative
arts subject we made compulsory for all
pupils taking GCSE and for the property
investment in our future musicians act
as an artists before it is too late to
reverse this most serious of declines
and can I just say an idea which isn't
mine from a charity which is this is
easy to do you just make Ofsted remove
outstanding status from any school that
doesn't thrive in the creative arts
sectors and then suddenly schools will
take this subject seriously because at
the moment there's no incentive for them
to do so Picasso said all shows are not
artists and the problem is keeping them
at artists as they go but the reality is
our system you can't measure creativity
in also because it doesn't actually
cater for it you know because we're
driven but what we have at our given
schools league system that doesn't
actually cater fit and I am I and I
think the shame of all this is is that
the funding squeeze means that the
the practice and the study of art is
getting dropped dropped off the
curriculum in state schools not however
in the private schools and this is what
every but this and this is what leads to
the fallacy that culture and arts belong
to the elites and and and it is a shame
that they are missing either but I also
agree with Nick because the reality for
many families whether you grew this or
not halfway is that some kids have to do
subjects and go in a certain route and
do a job that is gonna earn the money
they don't actually have a choice in
that there's a problem that there's been
a 26 percent decline in GCSE entries for
our subject since 2014 and the future of
this country's competitiveness if you
look ahead of our competitiveness when
we're competing globally it's the power
to have that research and innovation
which is all about creativity and at the
moment we do brilliantly we 1% of the
world's population we produce 16% of the
highest percent research papers in the
world but if we need to have that create
to be embedded from a young age we are
still the world's third largest cultural
exporter after China in America so even
with it not being in schools the way you
wanted to but still don't even the last
10 years that it's declined so seriously
that music and arts the kite and we will
see that in 10 years time because it
takes time for these children it's come
through an carrot I really would just
want to pick up on the idea that if you
need to earn a living you can't go into
the creative sector I've just said it's
the fastest growing part of the economy
guarantee that I agree I agree that this
is definitely a class issue privates
people are MPs who are implementing
these measures can afford to give their
children piano lessons and to send them
to schools that do arts and it's opening
a bigger class divide in access to very
living can I just can we have a listen
to this this is a journalist who's
commenting on on the way our economy is
going to evolve actually I think in the
future it's one of the few skills that
humans really have creativity is
something that we can do that a I can
never do plus the fact that these are
subjects that give you pleasure
throughout your life the key point there
is her point that she makes about AI
because actually III think looking at
that she's correct that if AI is gonna
replace math and engineering all these
other skill sets creativity is the only
one it can you imagine this there's a
book that I endorsed written by a
Stanford Graduate who invests in Silicon
Valley and
called the fuzzy and the techie and his
whole premises it's got to be a
combination of the two that's going to
be the most effective I'm going to have
to call school out or ring the bell on
this class in just a moment after I read
this but I think I speak for the
pledging team here and all pledges Karen
if we had a whip-round would you play
roll out the barrel on the piano
[Laughter]
education says the following we want all
pupils to have the opportunity to study
the Arts that is why music and art and
design are compulsory in the national
curriculum up to the age of 14 the 'back
or English Baccalaureate was designed to
be studied as part of a broad and
balanced curriculum it allows pupils
time to continue to study additional
subjects like the arts we are also
putting more money into arts education
programs and you are watching the pledge
on Sky News